j'aimerais rajouter un petit truc pour
celle là dis moi est ce que tu peux
est-ce qu'on peut amener un ballon
d'hélium quoi c'est par le climat est
mauvais pour la santé
les cordes vocales cedro cela fait drôle
oui bien bien bien je sais faire le
chemin donc et non pas aux relations de
mokoko a peur j'en ai dû par contre je m
attends attends ses deux potes mais t'es
pas aller à l'école
c'est de la ramée à ce qui s'y disait
ses deux potes kahn arrivé j'ai trouvé
nos c'est un peu c'est le génie qui sort
va être énorme boyer il raconte à son
pote web amérique est sorti il m'a dit
serveurs choisi entre avoir à chaque
heure une excellente mémoire études
choisies voir tous les clients sont là
et la ja jésus qui rentrent jésus
propres on y voit un mec un peu fatigué
il caresse la tête le mec fatigué cm en
pleine forme c'est jésus est a compris
le truc il avance vers un autre look il
est connu pour être sourd il fait ça au
perreux trouve louis vivent au fond du
bar et la boue des rillettes approche
page en arrêt maladie
comme quoi tu veux en faire une quinte à
la cdc des 3b qui sont dans le désert
vous a marqué machine à sucer pour 25
euros puis 25 et se faire une gâterie le
dia misy c'est incroyable mais 25 euros
et 7 euros 6,4 y y est le troisième cas
risée les gars je ne me faire 50 euros
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]